- [Hurts:] In the great before,
the average hot and extremely athletic man
could win MVP or a Super Bowl.
But now there is only Mahomes.
This year will be different.
Hey, is this MVP race?
I think I'm going to make a push
- Woo! Motor city lookin' MOTOR GRITTY.
- [Goff:] Coach, I don't think we quite fit in.
- [Lamar:] DADDY'S GOT A NEW SYSTEM.
Take THAT haters.
- [Mahomes/Hurts:] No one's really hating on you anymore.
- The lack of haters are my new haters!
Time to run it back!
- Indeed, it is time for a running back.
- I didn't say...
the ultimate system QB.
- Oh, what a lovely play!
- Careful, trap games ahead!
- [Hurts:] HA! Uh oh.
- [Tua:] Ha! We only let ourselves get stopped by good teams.
OH NO, GOOD TEAMS!
Hurry up, hurry up!
Uh, uh, uh.
- Ok Josh, just don't get distracted-
Oh GOSH, A DEFENDER!
I really got to stop these turnovers.
- That’s right. This year a defender has a chance!
Oh damn bro, I'm a mirage.
- [Mahomes:] Huh? What’s that?
- [chanting men:] CJ STROUD. CJ STROUD.
- BEHOLD! COLERIDGE BERNARD STROUD THE 4TH!
- Time to use my only weapon!
- Nah, shorty, you hang up first.
- Ok, time to lean on the defense.
- This is for last year!
- You gotta be more specific.
I beat a LOT of teams last year.
- [Mahomes/Hurts:] AHHH!
- [All:] I WILL WIN MVP!
- I will not.
- Just get me to mid-December.
- I'm trying my best.
- Oh, classic mainstream media
making the post-episode tag about us.
And not how much the f--king Giants suck.